former Fox News anchor gretchen carlson
levels explosive allegations against
arguably the most powerful man in news
was she fired for turning down sexual
advances warning this is very strong
subject matter
sometimes when women come forward about
sexual harassment they're seen as a
troublemaker and I just want women to
feel secure enough to come forward in
mass if this is actually still happening
for now that was journalist gretchen
carlson last year with ET the TV anchor
shared some of the challenges she says
she faced in TV news when her biggest
bombshell plane came today carlson is
accusing roger ailes the CEO and
chairman of fox news of sexual
harassment alleging he repeatedly
injected sexual and/or sexist comments
into conversations made sexual advances
by various means and said to her last
september quote I think you and I should
have had a sexual relationship a long
time ago and then you'd be good and
better and I'd be good and better the
suit alleges because of retaliation her
contract with the network was not
renewed Ailes in the network have not
responded to our request for comment
Gretchen who was crowned Miss America in
1989 wrote a memoir last year getting
real in it she told a cautionary tale
about trying to break into TV that she
says involved a top PR executive in LA
he basically took my head from the
passenger seat and shoved my head into
his crotch and I couldn't breathe
and again it was just like wow this is
kind of a bad business that I'm thinking
about getting into and then it happened
again in my real first job the 50 year
old also says being a young on-air
reporter turned dangerous for her back
in the early 90s I had a four year
stalker who terrorized me in two
different cities he also stalked my
parents and I basically lived every day
fearing that he would find me and
fearing for my life Gretchen says her
stalker passed away as for her new
filing there was one more interesting
moment from last year this question
about sexual harassment how did you kind
of put a stop to the sexual harassment
in the workplace and it's something that
you still encounter today or you put it
past you if you've know how to put a
stop to it yeah well these were early on
in my career I'm hoping that we've come
a long way in 2015